now we're ready to prove the law of
large numbers and while we're at it to
get it want to take a version which will
be the basis for a theory of sampling an
estimation so let's remember that the
law of large numbers says that if you
have n independent identically
distributed random variables with mean
mu and we let a n be their average then
for every positive number Delta the
probability that the average differs
from the mean by more than Delta goes to
zero as the number of trials increases
remember that means that if you tell me
what you think close means and what you
think very likely means then I can
guarantee that by doing enough trials
the the likelihood that the mean will be
that close to the average within will be
outside the tolerance is as small as you
thought small should be and we're ready
for the proof but in the proof there's
one extra fact that we're going to use
that we didn't explicitly mention which
is that not only are all of these random
variables identically distributed and
independent but we're actually going to
assume that they have a variance now not
every random variable has a finite
variance even if it has a finite mean in
fact there are random variables that
don't even have finite means and we'll
look at them on the last day of class
but so we're going to explicitly assume
that all of these random variables have
the same variance namely this went to
the standard deviation Sigma squared and
we'll be using that effect in the proof
all right now the first question to ask
is what is the expectation of the
average and the expectation of the
average is simply the expectation let's
prove that the expectation of the
average is by definition the expectation
of the sum of the ARS over N and by
additive 'ti of expectation that's the
sum of the expectation of each of the
ARS over N but each of them has
expectation mu so the numerator is n mu
in the ends cancel and so and sure
enough the average
the same expectation as each of the
individual variables each of the trials
now that'll lets us apply the chebyshev
bound to the random variable a n because
now we know what its mean is and its
mean is independent of n we can ask and
we can apply chebychev to the
probability that the average of n trials
are differs from its mean by more than
Delta and according to chebychev that's
bounded by the variance of the average
divided by n squared so I will have
proved the law of large numbers if I can
prove that the limit as n approaches
infinity of the variance goes to zero
because that means that the right hand
side will be going to 0 over Delta
squared namely going to 0 which is what
the law of large numbers says so we've
reduced the proof of the law of large
numbers to proving that the variance
goes to 0 as n approaches infinity where
a n is the average of n identically
distributed variables with common mean
mu and standard deviation Sigma
well let's calculate the variance of a n
way and again is the is the average the
sum of the ars over N and since we're
assuming independence of the R's the
variance sum rule and it just tells us
that this is the sum of the variances
now if we factor out the R 1 over n now
this is a factor of 1 over n times this
sum when we factor a constant out of the
variance it squares so the denominator
here becomes n squared and that's
critical and the numerator is the sum of
the n variances now each variance is
Sigma squared and we've got n of them so
we wind up with n Sigma squared over N
squared which is of course equal to
Sigma squared over N and Sigma square is
a constant and n is going to infinity so
sure enough the right hand side goes to
0 as n increases which is all we needed
to do to conclude the weak law of large
numbers now if we go back and look at
the
proof the only thing that it used about
the arse was that they had the same mean
mu and they actually had the same
variance Sigma Sigma squared and they
that the variance is added that was the
key step in the proof that the variance
of the sum of the ARS was equal to the
sum of the variances now a nativity of
variances only requires pairwise
independence and didn't even require the
hypothesis that they were mutually
independent and it didn't require the
previous proof that we went through did
not ever use the fact that the R's had
the same distribution that they may not
be identically distributed it was
sufficient that they have the same mean
and we can summarize what we really
proved when we thought we were proving
the law of large numbers we actually
proved a precise quantitative theorem
that says that if r1 through RN are
pairwise independent random variables
with the same finite mean mu and
variance Sigma Sigma squared and we let
a n be the average of those R of those n
variables then the probability that the
average differs from the mean by more
than Delta is less than or equal to this
definite number that we derived 1 over n
times Sigma over Delta squared and this
was what we previously proved when we
thought we were just proving the law of
large numbers we actually got this much
tighter quantitative theorem now what
this tells us here is that now if you
tell me what Delta is and you tell me
how small you want this to be well I
know what I'm given Sigma and I and you
give me the Delta that you specified and
since if you tell me how small you want
this to be I will know how big an n to
choose so this tells me how big a sample
I need how many tries I have to make in
order to get the probability that the
mean is close within a specified
tolerance Delta as small as you
specified and that is our independent
sampling thing that's why it's called
independent sampling because we now know
how big a sample is needed to estimate
the mean of any random variable with any
desired tolerance
any desired probability or of course the
variance has to be finite that tolerance
has to be positive tolerance is Delta
and the probability has to be less than
one